that's the new trump scandal this is a
big one look at how long
this new york times article is you can
for those of you listening you can
listen to the papers shuffle
very very long long concealed records
show trump's chronic losses and years of
tax avoidance the times obtained donald
trump's tax information
extending over more than two decades
revealing struggling properties
vast write-offs an audit battle and
hundreds of millions in debt coming due
okay i'm looking through i'm going
through all the pages
gosh man there's so is so long oh my
gosh
you know what word i can't find anywhere
here
illegal unlawful
breaking the law can't find any of that
here
because the new york times nowhere
alleges
that president trump broke the law or
did anything wrong he avoided
paying taxes tax avoidance is different
than tax evasion
tax evasion is illegal tax avoidance is
what everybody does
when they try to deduct as much as
possible as president trump bragged
about this very thing in 2016
when he said that paying the lowest tax
rate possible
makes him smart and if he didn't do that
probably you wouldn't want me to be your
president because he wouldn't have
very good financial sense it wouldn't
have very good economic sense this
actually gets back to that youtube
comment i mentioned at the top of the
show
they attack trump for opposite reasons
they attack trump for enriching himself
in office
and violating the emoluments clause and
basically using the presidency as a way
to line his pockets right that's what
they've been talking about for years
whether it's by selling extra rooms at
his hotels
or whether it's by taking bribes from
russia like hunter biden
you know the thing they were accusing
him of that actually
the democrats themselves were doing so
that's what they attacked him for first
now they're saying oh actually he's
broke actually he hasn't been making any
money actually
actually he's destitute and so when he
was rich and making a lot of money that
was why he was corrupt and we had to
impeach him
and now that he's broke and he's not
making any money that's why
he's corrupt and we have to impeach him
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
of course president trump is not broke
they've tried this on him for decades
now
it shows you the the financial and
business illiteracy
of many members of the media and the
political class which is they they don't
understand how this works so
hypothetical trump is denying that this
thing is real at all and we don't know i
mean obviously it was some corrupt
person who gave the new york times the
tax records in the first place because
they're not supposed to have access to
that
but let's say how could this
theoretically work why would trump pay a
very very low tax
rate in one year instead of another year
well we already know from the rachel
maddow show
that he paid millions and millions of
dollars in taxes with i think was 15
years ago he paid 38 million
in taxes or something remember that was
my doppelganger rachel maddow's big
reveal on her show we have trump's tax
records from o5 and yo he paid a ton of
money in taxes
but so let's say he pays 38 million
dollars in taxes one year
and then on all of his businesses takes
massive losses the next year
our tax code doesn't make you just pay
year by year by year by year it allows
you to
write down some losses if you make them
so you don't you so you don't have to
pay money
to the government on income that you
don't have
makes perfect sense beyond that there
are a lot of people now
talking about how president trump is a
business idiot
he's broke he's you know he's
a total nincompoop um
it is amazing to me how many people
who have not spent the past two decades
flying around in their own private 757s
all around the world are now
accusing president trump of not having
any business acumen it's amazing to me
it's amazing to me how many people
who haven't been regularly
living the high life penthouses in new
york properties all over the world
dating supermodels are accusing
president trump of not knowing how to
handle
his money i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you